[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and this week
we're talking about the classic strikes
in Aikido so what are the classic
strikes in Aikido and what are those
mean one of the things people like to
talk about a lot is there's a quote from
us Eva that he says the majority of
Aikido practice is a Timmy um and and I
say the majority because different
quotes some of them say says ninety
percent or ninety nine percent or 80
percent of here all kinds of numbers
turn around but but basically he had
alluded to at one point that the
majority of Aikido is about a Timmy and
Timmy means striking literally means to
hit the body with something so what does
that mean
and what does that have to do with
Aikido now if you hear something like
that you know the founder of the the
system saying that ninety percent of the
system is about striking then you would
think wolven Aikido must be a boxing
system or at least must be really good
at dealing with boxing I think he had
something a little different in mind and
we'll kind of hit on that in an episode
here but mostly right now we're gonna
talk about the traditional trikes you
see in Aikido and why they exist and
those can be really hard to understand
because they look silly until you put
them in the right context and in this
video I will show you before the video
is over how they will look completely
normal and you'll say oh I think the
strikes actually happen all over the
place right so people go oh man those
strikes look silly and no one ever uses
that and techniques need to be
modernized and updated that's not true
the techniques that are using iq2 for
striking are the techniques that are
commonly in place all over the world
today you've probably used them whether
you know it or not and you could watch
YouTube and find a million people using
them in conflict every day all the time
so the things I'm gonna show you in this
instantly by the end of this video
you'll understand where the strikes of
Aikido come from and that they're not
crazy they're in fact exactly the
strikes that they should be so I'm gonna
get Josh over here and we're gonna start
with showman and yokomen Josh all right
so we're talking about Timmy and Aikido
what is a Timmy Timmy comes from the
Japanese ah to to hit and then the me is
body so to hit the body so they hit the
body somehow and you wish you have said
that a majority of Aikido practice is
this hitting of the body and what does
that mean okay so let's talk about the
classic strikes of showman and yokomen
and let's talk about how goofy those
look right so
Josh and I are gonna be here in position
like this case let me show you showman
showman classic looks like this like
this like chopping right I could also do
that from the back hand coming from the
back hand that chopping right so the big
chop action yeah that looks silly right
so when was the last time you were in a
bar - dude square it up and wondered
when Shawn right so you never saw that
right you've never seen that okay so
well maybe if you lived in the 1960s
when karate was starting to get popular
you might have saw that in Los Angeles
but but anyway so so mostly though
you've never seen those things right so
that's not what people are doing not
doing these chops and you think well
maybe in the olden days they did chops
like that but nowadays they don't do
those chops right okay let's look at
yokomen what's the yokomen so yokomen he
has a chop from the side of the head
right so that looks like something
Captain Kirk mighty did but you know we
don't chop like it we don't chop you
know and and some people say oh you know
it's just a symbol for a big big looping
punch like that right so a big looping
punch maybe it could be that right but
but you know this looks silly right so
we do some kind of form a time like this
and give him a chunk right or a Java the
open comes from the back I give him a
chop now looks silly right so why would
people do those strikes it's dumb for
Aikido people to practice them and and I
remember when I was first started
practicing Aikido and I was really like
well okay cool I'll learn those because
since they says we should learn them but
in truth I'm gonna go learn to box and
so I did I wouldn't learn to box and and
then when I was boxing I was like oh
yeah this is stupid
I don't know why to do people for hit
like that and it all happened until the
first time I got in a fight with a
weapon and I realized that when someone
has a weapon like a stick the waist they
hit you are even like this like this or
like this those are the people waste
people hit you with the stick right so
if I had a stick I ain't like this guy
and it's like this this side of my body
I pop and bang like that what's that
that's the OP who yokomen if I had a
stick and I was out here like this what
would I do and pop him like that boom
what's that it's regular yokomen if I
just stick like this I'm threatening in
a hey you better get out of here better
never come bring it down like that and
what's that that's showman right so if
you put a stick in my hand suddenly this
strike makes a ton of sense right this
strike makes a ton of sense and this
strike makes a ton of sense right so
those are the classic strikes in Aikido
they're not from the olden days watch a
video of anyone hitting someone else
the stick and a guarantee as a matter if
they're super skilled or if they're kids
on a playground if they're hitting
someone else with a stick they're
hitting them basically like this or like
this or like this because that's the way
we hit with sticks you can maybe make
some low line attacks for the just
variations of that like you know
accounts for that so understand that
these strikes Yoko man deokman's showman
are absolutely regular strikes that are
done everyday in self-defense situations
all over the world so super super normal
to do I'm Christopher Hein thanks for
watching